the paradigm has shifted the world is
accelerating
[Music]
the science fiction of yesterday is
rapidly becoming the science fiction of
right
now do we withstand the tectonic shifts
in the world around us
how does a society thrive when the world
economy is undergoing constant
disruption
how do we continue to learn
when information is moving at the speed
of light
there are places that are ahead of the
curve
cities building the tools for
tomorrow we want to create
innovations that have a real world
impact
one day singapore can be self-sustained
in food production
[Music]
we are looking at the development of
singapore
40 years ahead of time
this city
could be a model for what's to come
this
is the city of the future singapore
the future of the world lies in its
urban environments
more than half the world's population
live in cities
and that number is growing
this rapid influx of people creates
possibility but it also creates
challenges
how can the cities of today grow and
thrive to become the places we want to
live in tomorrow
creating sustainable manageable human
spaces in the world's ever-expanding
cities
is a challenge facing governments across
the globe
and no one understands the complexity of
this challenge better than the planners
at singapore's housing and development
board
the agency in charge of creating living
spaces for about eighty percent of the
resident households in one of the most
densely populated cities
i'm an architect by training and i also
have a master's degree in planning so
i'm an architect planner
since 2010 dr chung's vision and
guidance has helped usher in a new era
of smart public housing for the hdb
allowing the city she loves to grow and
thrive despite significant challenges
[Music]
as an island city state we're only about
half the size of metropolitan london
we have to house 5.7 million people
and we are of course very land and
resource constrained
so that is the big challenge
but having said that over the years we
have managed to
develop singapore in a pretty
sustainable way and we are one of the
most livable cities in asia
when dr chong was a little girl
singapore was a vastly different city
it had a third of today's population
less than one percent of the current gdp
and little to no infrastructure
in just over five decades though this
tiny city-state has undergone a
remarkable transformation
singapore's hdb has built a million
flats
creating one of the most successful
public housing programs in the world
hdb is now looking to high-tech
innovative solutions to not only provide
enough living spaces for singapore
citizens but also improved quality of
life for decades to come
we have very sophisticated computer
models that help the architect planner
to improve the environmental quality in
the town so for example singapore is in
the tropics so we want to encourage the
breezes to come through
through computer simulation you can
actually position the blocks and the
public spaces in the parks in such a way
that help you to achieve this
[Music]
singapore does very long-term
comprehensive planning and that is very
important you are looking at the
development of singapore
40 years ahead of time and this is
important because it ensures that we
have sufficient land safeguarded to meet
all our development needs
singapore is planning decades ahead
in such a land scarce nation the
question is often not what to build but
where to build
[Music]
singapore's urban redevelopment
authority is in charge of identifying
the future needs of all singapore's land
it's the kind of challenge that draws in
the adventurous and the curious
i'm very much an urban person
the city is close to my heart and even
more so having
worked in detail on the plans over the
last 20 over years
for andrew and the ura sometimes that
work means creating land from nothing
a process known as land reclamation
since independence in 1965
singapore has used reclamation to
increase its land mass by about 23
percent
one of the most striking examples of
this and perhaps a vision that cities
across the world may adopt
is singapore's marina bay
a vast engineering project that has been
decades in the making
[Music]
when i first started work with ura
marina bay was just a vacant tract of
land
it was only
maybe 10-15 years ago that we actively
started development of the area
andrew was part of the team that drew up
the plan for marina bay and translated
it into reality
its development dramatically increased
the footprint of singapore
but it was designed with the needs of
its citizens in mind
the traditional central business
district just comprises of office space
then is only used nine to five five days
a week so as we've planned marina bay
we've also looked to bring in
complementary uses so the idea is you
create a mix use precinct that the
activities carry on 24 7
and seven days a week
to make the round-the-clock marina bay
model work the ura needed infrastructure
in landscape singapore that meant going
underground
using precision designed layers of
essential services
including water and electrical tunnels
pedestrian and commercial spaces
transportation infrastructure like
highways and subways and even
telecommunications super highways
these hidden underground systems have
been designed to meet the needs of
singapore for the next 50 years
but some in singapore are looking beyond
that
already imagining the cities of the far
future
i actually think that the future of
singapore is not just about increasing
the density around transportation
nodes of activity i actually think it's
about exploring air rights as well
jason pomeroy has grand visions for his
city
the award-winning architect of
singapore's first zero carbon house the
bee house
his designs are pushing the boundaries
of how singapore might look more than 50
years from now
think about creating structures over
roads over motorways topping up above
existing structures the rooftops today
might be sky court sky gardens of
recreation
if cities expand upwards into the skies
conventional methods of road
transportation may no longer be
effective
perhaps the future of urban
transportation will play a major part in
shaping the way we live
and then all of a sudden you're going to
need to think about how to get people up
there you know if you were to fast
forward 50 years from now we already see
drone technology becoming so advanced
why are we not sticking people into
those drones again a bit like blade
runner all of a sudden your sky courts
your sky gardens even your private
terraces to your condo is actually a
landing platform for your own
personalized drone
though the idea of us flying to work may
be decades away
drone technology is advancing rapidly
and could become integral to the
evolution of transportation in the
cities of tomorrow
in singapore the government has thrown
its support behind an advanced program
to test the limits of drone capabilities
in the world's rapidly expanding urban
environments
[Music]
skyways is airbus's project
that is exploring this urban air
delivery domain
or basically cargo delivery with drones
project
[Music]
the drone that we're using is actually
fully customized or fully designed by
our team here in singapore
to ensure maximum safety in the air the
drones have multiple aerospace grade
navigation systems
so that if one system malfunctions it
can rely on others to fly to its
destination
[Music]
the packages that we can deliver by
design today is up to four kilograms
what we understand is that four
kilograms would cover perhaps about
eighty eighty five percent of all the
packages that are parcel deliveries that
are done today
once the package has been delivered to
its slot the mailbox automatically sends
a personalized code to the customer
so they can pick up the package 24 7.
and just like that
also comes back
[Music]
in airbus one of our visions is what we
call urban air mobility
so flying taxis for example
skyways is about enabling this
technology
it's about looking and moving towards
a future
where we have than
a flying transportation means in an
unread setting
singapore innovators are imagining and
experimenting the what's next
for urban travel
drone technology may be the next
revolution liberating commuters from
their two-dimensional travel
but the challenges facing all of our
cities may be more elemental than where
we will build and how to get around
providing food and water for the
millions of people
that will pack into our urban
environments
could be
the biggest challenge yet
[Music]
as urban populations rise the world will
face unprecedented challenges
how to house transport and most
importantly feed its people
in the future as rural populations
decrease ensuring food stability will be
key in landscape singapore it's a
challenge that is already being
confronted
right now 93 of produce is imported in
to singapore and that's because there
just simply isn't enough land to do
farming practices
benjamin swann came to singapore as an
engineer on the marina bay sands project
but having fallen in love with the city
he recognized a challenge and an
opportunity
to help the nation towards its goal of
food sustainability
ben is developing a new way to grow food
not just in singapore but in any urban
environment
sustanair is a controlled environment
agriculture farm
we effectively replicate what's
happening outside in nature to grow
impossible products in impossible places
singapore is a trailblazer in this
technology
having opened the world's first
commercial vertical farm in 2012
now sustaineer through their patented
processes are able to grow produce
indoors without sunlight and without
soil
what we actually have done is we've come
up with our own system here to introduce
the seas directly into the foam cubes
so what that does is ensures we have 100
germination success
this room has been specially designed to
take the plant from its initial
germination through to a mature state
where we can introduce into the main
grow rooms
these large-scale growing rooms are
astonishing feats of agricultural
technology
the precision calibration of the growing
environment allows these new age farmers
to optimize cultivation at every stage
in the plant's growth
we control the air temperature the
humidity the light durations the light
wavelength we control the dissolved
oxygen in the water as well as the
carbon dioxide saturation there
in these closely monitored growing rooms
sustaineer is creating food history
first ever singaporean grown
strawberries we're actually growing
three varieties in this room
what we've learned through controlled
environment agriculture
we can actually
emphasize certain characteristics of the
plants so
without using gmo we can make our kale
softer we can actually make it sweet a
lot of the singaporeans don't like their
products to be bitter so we took it into
our r d lab and what we found was by
manipulating the air temperature and
humidity and
also the wavelength of light and the
growth cycles we were able to create
this great product that we're growing
today
not only is this farm able to produce
vegetables perfectly calibrated for
singaporeans but the techniques could
provide vital farming areas for the
densely populated cities of the future
[Music]
traditional land farming grows produce
outside on a flat linear area
sustania's system grows food inside in
any building
expanding agriculture's footprint up
into the sky
so what vertical farming means for
places like singapore that has very
little or has land scarcity is that we
can leverage buildings to grow products
and with the efficiency that we have
within our footprint we believe one day
that we could actually produce enough
produce indoors to stay in singapore's
map
fresh available food will be a necessity
in our cities not only to feed citizens
but also to keep them healthy
as populations age and the incidence of
diabetes continues to rise across the
developed world singapore like all
cities needs to encourage its citizens
to eat smart and well
[Music]
we wanted to deploy food and beverages
okay as a tool to manage it could be
health it could be wellness it could be
performance and of course also for
fitness as well
believe it or not these colorful
sculptures are edible
they are the creations of dr lee man wai
a scientist at singapore polytechnic's
food innovation and resource center
using the latest breakthroughs in
technology she is creating food tailored
to the exact caloric and nutrition needs
of singapore's senior citizens
we wanted to look at personalized
nutrition for a target growth people so
what we started off is basically looking
at people with different lifestyles or
otherwise looking at people with
different health conditions
to realize her vision dr lee
collaborated with bioengineer mark wong
to build a piece of wearable tech that
can monitor a person's nutritional
requirements
what we have developed here at singapore
polytechnic is what we call the
intercept system it's in a form factor
for watch the app it's pulling data from
the
from the wearable so this data can then
be fed to algorithms to compute
specialized individual
nutrients that are customized for the
individual so a 3d printer could then
use this data
and
print out the appropriate nutrient
values suitable for that individual dr
lee's system is one of the first of its
kind in singapore and perhaps the world
to pair wearable tech with 3d printing
to create food with personalized
nutritional values this particular
printer actually has a beautiful way of
allowing us to customize nutrition so
there should be probably a chicken rice
that is actually high in calcium some
that is actually good for potassium and
different types of vitamins and minerals
that is accustomed
while still an experimental prototype
the potential is staggering
this jelly packs a punch with the
necessary nutrients for optimizing
health and even preventing diseases
with greater sets of data from each
individual we can now create a whole
library or database and identify trends
by using machine learning or using ai so
that is extremely powerful in the near
future to be able to predict potential
health issues and mitigate those health
issues in population centers before
events occur
through imaginative planning and
technological innovation singapore is
finding new ways to house and feed its
growing population
but perhaps one of the biggest
challenges facing any global city
will be ensuring a constant safe supply
of that most pressures of resources
water
singapore currently uses 2 billion
liters of water a day
the most efficient source of fresh water
is rain
and to capitalize on this resource the
nation is crisscrossed with an extensive
network of rivers and canals that
channel every last precious drop of rain
into 17 storage reservoirs
[Music]
about two-thirds of singapore is a water
catchment area that's about 400 plus
square kilometers
so water that falls on the catchment
area it will find its way into our
drains and canals which are linked to
one of our reservoirs
singapore's catchment system is
extensive and efficient
but to collect rainwater you need land
and lots of it
singapore is a small island so we are
limited in terms of the catchment area
that we have and also now with the
changing weather patterns the
water coming from rain it's a bit
unpredictable
so we've moved on to more weather
resilient water sources like
desalination
as the world warms every city will need
to find fresh solutions to provide their
citizens with clean water
in singapore the public utilities board
is already looking to the future
experimenting with new techniques to
push the water potential of the little
red dot
looking ahead our cities need to
overcome a variety of challenges
[Music]
rapid urbanization will present problems
of growth housing and food
sustainability
but none may be more crucial than the
access to fresh water
singapore currently imports about half
of its daily water requirement
in the next three decades though the aim
is to ensure water sustainability
to do so planners are looking to a
resource the island nation has in
abundance
seawater
i always call this a new toy really it's
kind of a toy for us but seriously
it's a plant that's designed with
robustness reliability it's fully
automated
hugh kitsan oversaw the construction of
a brand new state-of-the-art water
facility the tuas desalination plant
we've been working on this project for
the last just over two years to get it
from a green field and up to the state
that you see right behind me
a functional 30 million gallons per day
desalination plant
[Music]
the twas desalination plant is a modern
marvel of precision engineering
in landscape singapore its footprint is
a mere 100 meters by 300 meters that's
roughly the size of three football
fields
this may seem large but it is a
relatively small footprint compared to
plants of its kind around the world
when we did the design in the
construction it was quite a challenge
that you got to make sure that they're
all stacked and arranged in like a lego
manner that it all fits nicely into a
puzzle and it forms the plant what you
see today
despite its small footprint the twas
desalination plant houses one of the
world's most powerful technologies for
producing fresh water from the seed
reverse osmosis filters
[Music]
that's actually the heart of the plant
where the salt in the sea water gets
separated or removed from the water
the white tubes in there is the reverse
osmosis membrane where filtered water
will be pushed through the membrane
this high-tech process is a key part of
preparing singapore for the future
but conventional water desalination is
energy intensive
the electricity you would need to
desalinate enough water for just one day
of singapore's needs could power
singaporean household for a thousand
years
to save energy and reduce the cost of
water desalination the pub is now
investing in new research
evoqua is a company working on the
desalination process of tomorrow
we are demonstrating our next ed
technology for seawater desalination
[Music]
electrodialysis uses electricity to
remove salt from seawater
pairs of electrodes are placed in a
stream of salt water with one positive
electrode and one negative
the positively charged sodium ions are
attracted to the negative electrode and
the negatively charged chlorine ions are
attracted to the positive electrode
this concentrates the salt around the
electrodes the process is repeated until
the water is salt free
now we are building a demonstration plan
with a capacity of 3800 meter cube per
day we have plans to further scale up
this technology with a capacity of 100
000 meter cube per day
singapore's innovations in housing food
and water are giving us a glimpse of how
a forward-thinking city might solve some
of the challenges it faces
but these solutions will come at a price
fast secure and thriving economies will
be essential for facing an uncertain
future
and perhaps no nation understands this
better than singapore
the financial sector is a very very
critical sector for singapore almost 12
percent of our gdp comes from the sector
so you understand how critical for us to
ensure that the sector is a vibrant
sector it is competitive it attracts the
best possible
ideas
as the chief fintech officer of the
monetary authority of singapore
swapnandu mahanti needs to ensure that
the nation sets a world standard for the
financial sector
this boils down to one thing technology
innovation
most of the services and financial
sector are going to be powered by
technology
[Music]
in 2016 singapore announced project ubin
a new fintech experiment using
blockchain technology
traditionally banks keep a record of all
transactions on their own centralized
ledger which is susceptible to
manipulation by hackers
but project ubin keeps all records on a
blockchain this means that identical
copies of the ledger are kept on a
distributed network of computers around
the world
these computers check in with each other
to ensure that their copy of the ledger
is correct
if one of the copies does not match the
others it is rejected and replaced with
a copy that the majority of ledgers
agree is correct
to tamper with the blockchain to steal
money a hacker would need to hack a
majority of the computers on the network
simultaneously a virtual impossibility
the real killer use case is cross-border
transfer today it takes two to three
days to move money between two countries
the whole os is transfer so if we can
apply a technology like blockchain
it may give us that opportunity to
reduce the time to do cross-border
transfer and may also reduce the
expenses where we move money from a
country to big country
singapore has long been known as a
financial hub home to major banks from
around the world
with project ubin singapore has ensured
that it will stay ahead of the pack when
it comes to fintech
in a country short on natural resources
the motto is innovate or die
and singapore has taken up that
challenge
with a startup culture catapulting the
nation
into the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ideas are one of the intangible
resources that power
cities singapore is capitalized on the
nation's creative dna to support and
usher in a new wave of innovative
companies
one of the biggest start-up hubs is st
engineering's tech incubator
inno sparks
we are focused on solving some of the
urban challenges
particularly solutions in smart cities
as well as health tech
medical technology is a 350 billion
dollar global industry one that thrives
on the latest ideas
start alignment
like alango's revolutionary automated
needle targeting system
with end system we are able to automate
the entire needle alignment process
making it very stress-free for the
doctors they can align the needle to the
target at a fraction of the time it is
more accurate
more than just a surgical assistant
alan's robot can actually help train the
next generation of surgeons
typically for surgeons to be expert in
terms of puncture he has to puncture
more than 150 times but with such a
device which is smart automated junior
surgeons probably just required about
40 to 50 puncture and they could be an
expert in the field of puncture
innosparx has also been key in
developing life-saving technologies to
solve global health problems
my name is jerome i'm the head of
engineering at inno sparks and i'm also
the lead engineer for air plasma mask
so we actually started the project
development in 2013 when singapore was
hit with severe haze
during the 2013 southeast asian haze
crisis large-scale wildfires blanketed
the region in impenetrable smog
shattering all records and pollution
indexes
stores sold out of high quality air
filtration masks
worse yet
parents were dismayed to learn that all
masks on the market were built for
adults
we actually went to do a 3d facial
scanning of more than 850 children and
adults
and then using an algorithm that we
developed in-house proprietary we came
up with three sizes of masks that fits
children adults to the elderly
using thermal imaging the benefits of
these masks leap into focus
[Music]
we can see that actually the mask itself
stays pretty much purple this is a quick
way to show that the ventilator is
actually effective in venting heat from
the mask
while a vital part of singapore's
economy the tech scene is not just about
software or hardware
at its core
it is about hardware
providing for its citizens
we want to
create
innovations that have a real-world
impact so we take a very user-centered
approach
singapore's digital economy is providing
real tangible benefits to people and
some of its brightest inventors are
focusing on the far future
local startup transferfy has developed a
technology that could change the way we
think about electricity
wireless power transfer is
inherently
being able to transfer power
wirelessly
we're using radio frequency to be able
to transfer power
in terms of the construct behind it is
electromagnetic waves
essentially power within a waveform
the custom-built transmitter converts
electrical current into electromagnetic
waves
using a complex algorithm this wave is
modulated and focused into a tight beam
transmitted to an array of antennas
using radio frequency
the receiver harvests the radio
frequency waves and converts them to
direct current which is able to power
electrical devices
[Music]
the system is ready now so the signal is
now generating i think now we are ready
to switch on the power amplifier
[Music]
t5 logo there it's on now
it switches on without any uh any wires
threaded to it no batteries nothing it's
all power through air
this simple demonstration gives a hint
of the enormous potential of the system
as the technology is scaled up to
further distances it could revolutionize
every industry that relies on
electricity
creating the world's first long-range
safe and efficient wireless power
networks
there's a lot of uses i mean it's
ubiquitous technology and you can use
wireless power transfer distribution for
almost anything
from consumer electronics to medical
devices to offshore renewables
to sensors you know for automation
singapore's digital startups are
dreaming up ingenious new technology
proving that perhaps the greatest
resource will need in the future
is imagination
in tomorrow's super connected smart
cities
every aspect of our lives could be
affected by the constantly changing
world of digital technology
preparing the next generation for this
future is top of mind for most educators
of today
in singapore that preparation starts
early
using tech tools to teach children the
building blocks of a digital mindset
including the most basic skill needed
for coding
sequential learning
sequential learning it seems easy for us
adults but it's actually not easy for
them at all to know who comes first and
who comes next
all right children we're going to go
over there then we're going to find your
dry leaves and then we're going to put
them in your
basket okay let's go
i feel that there's a lot of skills that
they can gain from having the tech toys
as well yeah learning problem solving
skills communication skills language
skills as well and also they learn how
to problem solve sequential as well
one
two three four we need to press four
steps
good job
the playmaker program there are three
tech toys the b board is something that
is very friendly and very easy to
operate because there's only a few
buttons for the children to use so for
example we have the forward backward
turn left and turn right button
try to show us some people
i would say it's a little bit high-end
other thinking whereby children will
have to sequence the block first put it
in order and they have to scan the
barcode so for kimbo it won't function
if they don't start with a begin block
and end it with the end block so during
that time children actually get to
do a trial and error to see whether it
works or not
[Music]
these tech toys introduce children to
advanced learning concepts
in doing so they are arming future
generations of singaporeans with the
skills necessary for computer
programming and literacy
without exposing them to too much screen
time
this dynamic new approach to education
is of critical importance for parents
helping to prepare their children for
the workplaces of the future
i've got three boys they are 12 11 and
youngest is four
since i'm in the finance line the
current way to go is the fintech
the concern for how my kids are going to
cope with the
new change and their career force has
always been there
definitely i feel these tools will
actually help children to prepare in the
workforce in the future because we are
actually building the foundation for
example the foundation of language the
foundation of problem solving the
foundation of communicating with people
tech literacy is not just a challenge
for newer generations
[Music]
as populations around the world age the
need to become digitally literate cuts
across all age brackets
singapore is tackling this problem head
on with proactive efforts to provide
tech education to all of its citizens
ensuring none are left offline
journey to digital fluency came at a
clinic held by singapore's info
communications media development
authority
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
singapore's focus on training all of its
citizens for the future is nurturing a
highly educated versatile and connected
population
connectivity and community will shape
the world of tomorrow
and in singapore that sense of community
is already revealing itself
in new
and surprising ways
we are racing towards a future that will
be dominated by technology
in the decades to come
dedicated citizens will find ways to
harness that technology to make a
positive impact enhancing lives to
creative innovation
in singapore technology is already being
created that will care for the nation's
most vulnerable
we try to provide sleep wellness for
newborn babies and also premature babies
hi how are you
hi hi frank yeah
so what you do is that you actually put
a baby on it
and after you'll be sleeping for about a
minute we can give you the breath calm
and know how well your baby is sleeping
when a baby sleeps they have a lot of
periodic breathing that means they
breathe and they stop they breathe and
they stop
now this happened to two percent of the
newborn baby
but it happened to 60 percent of
premature babies
[Music]
periodic breathing dramatically reduces
oxygen flow
which can have a detrimental effect on a
baby's growth and even their cognitive
development
the breath optic system uses fiber optic
technology to help monitor this
for frank this project is personal
i think one of the
the driving force of us inventing this
product
was because
24 years ago
[Music]
i i had a premature sun
at that point in time
i bought whatever that's available to
try to monitor the baby
and actually for for one month
me and my wife did not sleep in the same
room because we took 12 hour shift
to stare at the baby
so we took turns to to look after my son
for for a while so when we were able to
use the optic technology
optic fiber technology to create such a
sensor
we really know what we want
because i was in that position before
and your son is okay now oh my side's
perfect
just life and kicking and well
the spirit of using technological
ingenuity to improve lives has been
built into the city itself
with green corridors and protected
parkland keeping singapore from becoming
a concrete jungle
in its efforts conserve and protect its
status as a city in a garden
and parks is employing the power of
technology
so one of the tools that we use is
called the sg bioatlas app it's a free
citizen science based app where
everybody can download and you could
record wildlife things that you see in
singapore it could be at your park it
could be in the forest in singapore and
using this data you can develop some
conservation or management strategies
where we could conserve certain habitats
or protect certain green spaces
the app is empowering singapore's
citizens to play a meaningful role in
the conservation and protection of the
city's incredible biodiversity
[Music]
those birds over there they are the
jungle full
they're like chickens
but they are technically not chickens
right
[Music]
i'm a working mom
in the daytime i will usually be working
and by the night time i'll be probably
down on my couch and watching television
i spend most of my time on the phone
watching youtube playing games
not only is the citizen science program
helping n-parks maintain singapore's
rich ecosystem but also helping people
build connections with green spaces
and each other
singapore is a scarce of land
so what we need is to preserve what we
have now and using the technology we are
able to provide feedback to national
park
on the species that we still have in
singapore
as the modern world rapidly marches
towards urbanization our future cities
will face unprecedented pressures
innovation and technological
advancements will help bring profound
change
to how we live
how we work
and how we learn
in singapore that change
is already underway
it feels like we are part of building
and creating a singapore that is vibrant
safe and also sustainable for the people
now and also for the future
if we can do it here in singapore we can
literally do it anywhere in the world
and we are excited almost on a everyday
basis we are motivated by the fact that
we actually can make a difference
i heard from one nobel prize winner only
a prepared mind can see opportunity
and we are using this opportunity by
getting ourselves prepared
[Music]
[Music]
you